like all great books you have [ __ ]
stories in there and you oh yes
um yes i got a doozy
he's got a doozy he had met his uh who
now wife yes
i finally got a girlfriend lauren and
my friend at nick stoller actually the
guy directed neighbors he he had a
bachelor party in
um mexico um and when i when you go to
mexico everyone's like don't drink the
water and don't
eat freshly rinsed vegetables um
for whatever reason i had a lot of salad
that i i don't even eat a lot of salad
normally but
for whatever i think when someone told
me not to i think his students are like
don't eat the salad i was like [ __ ] you
i'm on [ __ ] vacation eat all the
salad i want so
i ate vegetables and salad and then
i went the the bachelor party ended i
went back
uh i went back to l.a lauren picked me
up from the airport which felt very
adult
um and very like meaningful is the first
time i've ever had a girl do that you
know
every morning i would walk her out to
her car um before she drove to work
yes a gentleman it was sweet so that
morning
i uh got up um and was getting i got
dressed
and i was in the bathroom i was looking
at myself in the mirror just kind of
being like you kind of did it man like
you're in a relationship you're gonna
walk this girl out to her car
everything's going great and then i
uh shat my pants as as terribly as a
human possibly could no warning just
keep flying [ __ ] like
a complete it's like not like like a
complete [ __ ]
and then at that moment lord pops her
head at the bathroom and it's like you
ready to go are you ready to walk me out
to the car
and we were early enough for the
relationship that i could not
be like no i just shot my bad steps
not romantic i was concerned that that
would
that would be bad and so girls get
turned off by that i've noticed
i think i've heard that's not a cool
thing right
and so i was like yeah let's do this
ready to walk you out and i live
on like a second story walk-up apartment
and i walk down and she has not smelled
it thank god and then we get
how is that possible seth i was honestly
i think maybe i like rushed down maybe i
like hustled down this dance or maybe i
sent her down before me
and kind of followed her up a little bit
until you didn't wash the entire face
you just gotta stay up when and then we
got to the street and i remember hoping
her car was parked close and it was not
it was like a block up it was like a
block away
so i'm just like because like once
you've shat yourself the last thing you
want to do also is
walk a block in any direction just
you're just working in there just like i
know you're just filming like what is
happening down there
what is the situation how much worse
i'm squishing it around i'm smearing
around there
it's just a terrible thing with a woman
and so i'm just i'm walking into her car
and i know she's gonna like hug me and
kiss me
when we get to the car and that i'm like
playing that out of my head
just like how do i keep my ass out how
do i just like
how do i keep this going by some miracle
i got her to the car
i guess i stuck my ass as far away from
her as possible i kissed her
she drove away and she never found out
about it i just
i remember standing there on the street
like covered in [ __ ]
just watching her drive away being like
maybe one day you'll marry that woman